hurricane Harvey is blasting Texas this
morning and this is what it feels like
storm was a category 4 when it made
landfall late last night northeast of
Corpus Christi in Rockport with winds at
130 miles an hour and heavy rains a
tornado watch has been posted for most
of the coast all the way to Louisiana
the hurricane caused tens of thousands
of residents to flee more than 210
thousand people are without electricity
this morning Harvey is now a category 1
storm but it could strengthen again it
has already brought storm surges of up
to 12 feet and is expected to cause
extensive flooding over the next few
days from as much as 3 feet of rain we
have a team of correspondents stationed
throughout eastern Texas we start with
Manuel Bojorquez in Victoria which is
just a few miles from the eye of the
storm
Manuel good morning good morning we are
definitely seeing the worst of hurricane
Harvey as it churns inland here in
Victoria maximum sustained winds at 90
miles per hour wind gusts can top 100
miles per hour there in ermand at times
but you really get a sense standing out
here of how dangerous and possibly
destructive or even destructive as we've
seen in other parts of Texas this storm
will be I can tell you the situation
here really started to deteriorate
around 2:00 a.m. that's when the power
went out you could hear transformers
blowing powerlines coming down and what
was really scary for people here
including us was that the hotel started
to sway so a lot of people right now out
here have decided to wait it out in the
lobby of the hotel away from windows as
dangerous as the wind situation is right
now and will be for hours the real
concern for officials here in Victoria
is the rainfall they're not expecting to
get merely inches they are expecting
feet of rain up to two and a half feet
from this storm
so the concern they've been mentioning
is quote catastrophic flooding that's
not language that is used lightly around
here and that's why they wanted people
to get out of the way before the storm
some pea
did that we saw yesterday others decided
to write it out but the big problem
going forward is that it could take days
to really assess damage here and any
recovery because the storm is expected
to linger
now you're getting one perspective from
us here of how bad the situation is but
just to give you a wider perspective yes
we are right here close to the eye of
the storm right now but there are more
than seven million Texans living in some
sort of state of disaster right now and
again this situation is only worsening
for some of them right now
Anthony Manuel Bojorquez in Victoria men
will be careful thank you